damn dude memories huh so high memories
bro dude memories are crazy
because
like you tell that
story to me so much if if you were to
tell a story to me so much you might
then
uh eventually believe I was there yeah
you know what I'm saying you're talking
about the way memory yeah yeah dude it's
interesting yeah there's been crazy
studies done on this and it's nobody
understands you cannot like take like if
somebody's describing something that
happened 20 years ago it's just you
might as well be
telling
a someone about a a Michael kryon novel
it didn't happen basically basically
yeah it basically didn't happen
basically that's the right way to think
of it though and even if you tell the
story over and over again it's like a
game of telephone with your yourself
yeah you're playing telephone with
yourself yeah and you you tell the story
over and over again and then this
happened and then you're like as you
tell wait this what happened I said this
so much I don't connect with it anymore
did it even really happen bro it's crazy
dude the craziest thing is that that's
so true that we sometimes take other
people's stories think of them as our
own but they're someone else's have you
ever done that I've done that a handful
of times and it's such a strange feeling
because like the person you're telling
it to or if you're telling it to a group
one of them will be like that happened
to me that that's a Louis CK joke it is
yeah no way yeah he's like you ever tell
St
yeah oh my God you tell a story about
someone you tell a story that's someone
else's and you tell to the person that
is that it is and you telling the story
and they're like that happened to me but
he's saying he steals the story on
purpose yeah no no I don't know actually
I don't remember happened so long ago
and I don't remember right yeah I mean I
remember I read this study once on
people in their memories of 9/11 yeah
and they would reinter these same people
that they interviewed like a week after
911 I don't know how they put the study
together so fast yeah but they just
happened to be right place right time
and then they would reinw them a month
later a year later 10 years later and
like their memories of 9/11 which
everyone obviously thinks we all
remember where we were when we found out
what we were doing how we felt these
people were just like with specific
memories a couple days afterwards had
like zero ability to recall but not in
the way that you would expect you'd
think someone who can't recall something
would be like [__] I don't remember they
had they had specific ideas about what
the memories were but they were wrong
why because that's how brains work man
oh wow brains don't you ever heard that
expression nature AB hords a vacuum M
it's like you can't actually have
nothing you're in in this case it's the
brain like the brain will create stuff
that makes sense to have happened but
didn't actually happen if you have a
hole in a memory like if if you're
telling a story that you 80% remember
your brain will tell you you remember
100% of it CU it'll just Bridge gaps
almost automatically for you so we're
constantly doing that about everything
we remember or think or feel or project
in the future about other things it's
like we don't even realize that we're
doing it that's unfair no way dude
that's the most fair thing that's that's
like how it's amazing that our brains do
that we're lucky but but they make [__]
up yeah they didn't happen they and then
you get misinformation and then people
right but they also allow us to what we
are in other ways you know what I'm
saying oh like good storytellers yeah I
a really good Storyteller yeah okay
prove it I I did I did I did wow wow the
dumbest response you
know yeah dude I don't I don't believe
anything anyone ever says period well
that's bad yep but it is hard to it is
hard man it is that it is that no but it
really is it is hard the other day I was
with Kristen and a bunch of her friends
and she said to her
friends uh I okay so I farted I guess I
don't even really
remember wow dude and and I and I was
like sorry I don't give a [__] I farted
sure yeah okay and and she was like I
don't remember if I actually farted or
not but I was talking about farting and
then she was like um you're you said
that you
uh think it's bad for the body if you
hold farts inside because they need to
come out that it's unhealthy and I and
and and Kristen said this this is
something Kristen says and stands by and
she said I said it about to me and I
said Kristen hold on a second hold on a
second dude either I'm crazy or this is
something you say she's like no you do I
was like think about what you're saying
who believes this and she goes like this
oh I do oh I say you say this she's like
you're right I knew it was one of us so
she at least admitted it then
most yeah but it's something that she
stands by it's something that she said
over and over again until you made her
think about it no no no she stands by
the the thing about cuz when she farts
I'm like don't do that and she's like
it's bad for you if you keep it in I'm
like no it's not you send a burping
weird